[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
westliche Militärexperten und die
Ukrainer selbst verweisen ja immer
wieder darauf dass kein nato-soldat je
unter den Bedingungen gekämpft hat unter
denen die Ukraine ist tun müssen nämlich
weitgehend ohne Absicherung aus der Luft
das ist ein Grund warum sie immer wieder
um westliche Kampfflugzeuge baten die
Niederländer und die Dänen haben wir
jetzt entsprechende Lieferungen zugesagt
diese F16 müssen aber auch von
ausgebildeten Piloten geflogen und von
Technikern gewartet werden so schnell
wird man sie wohl nicht im Einsatz sehen
aber die Zusage als solche ist für
Präsident selenski ein Erfolg und für
seine Bevölkerung ein psychologisches
Moment
seine Rede ist eigentlich vorbei heute
Mittag im Kopenhagen da will wo Leute
mir selenski noch etwas loswerden es
geht um die Zeit nach einem möglichen
Sieg der Ukraine
vielleicht ist es nicht üblich dass ein
Präsident so etwas sagt aber ich will es
sagen ja wir werden zu euch kommen
vielleicht werden wir zusammen sitzen
irgendwo
und dann
werden wir eines sagen
ein Prost auf den Sieg und ein Präsident
der so gelöst ist wie selten am Tag
nachdem er endlich diese Zusage hat die
ersten NATO-Staaten wollen in seinem
Land westliche F16 Kampfjets schicken
Dänemark verspricht 19 Jets weitere die
Niederlande das stört für den Moment
weniger dass die erste Handvoll erst zu
Silvester eintreffen soll manche erst
2025 was heute zählt ist die Botschaft
verstanden wird dass ich die NATO
Alliierten hier auf lange Sicht
verpflichtet haben zur Lieferung von
kämpft jetzt gehören schließlich
langfristige Wartungen langfristiges
Training eine Lieferung die Grundsatz
Fragen aufwirft wie groß ist das
Vertrauen in die Ukraine bei der Linken
ziemlich klein
wir brauchen einen Fokus auf Diplomatie
und Bemühungen
zufriedensverhandlungen weil die
Eskalation natürlich ganz enorm groß ist
gerade auch durch Waffen die auch auf
russischen und gegen russisches
Territorium eingesetzt werden können
tatsächlich theoretisch könnten die
Kampfjets bis weit in russisches Gebiet
hinein angreifen die Niederlande und
Dänemark aber Vertrauen der ukrainischen
Zusage genau das nicht zu tun und so
fragen heute viele mit neuem Druck warum
zögert dann die deutsche Regierung
Taurus Marschflugkörper zu liefern also
Raketen mit hoher Reichweite
es war abzulegen ob man die Ukraine in
ihrem Verteidigungskampf unterstützt und
wenn man diese Frage im Prinzip ja hat
dann muss man auch das liefern was
erforderlich ist wenn die Niederländer
und denen die F 16 schicken sollte der
Bundeskanzler und das Bundeskanzleramt
jetzt ein Herz über den Zaun werfen und
die Freigabe für den Taurus geben wann
also entscheidet Berlin die
Außenministerin lässt die Frage heute
unbeantwortet das ist auf jeden Fall
darauf ankommt dass er mir glaube ich in
den letzten anderthalb Jahren nicht nur
eindrücklich sondern auf brutale Art und
Weise erleben müssen auf jeden Tag kommt
es an das würde wohl Leute mir selenski
sicher genau so formulieren
der Ball soll es in Moskau Pläne geben
mehrere hunderttausend Russen in der
besetzten Hafenstadt mariopol
anzusiedeln das berichten ukrainische
Medien überraschend während ein solches
Vorgehen nicht eroberte Gebiete mit
eigenen Leuten zu besiedeln um Fakten zu
schaffen ist ja eine sehr alte Methode
der Kriegsführung auch während des
Stalinismus wurde das exzessiv
durchgeführt mit Massen Deportationen
und Umsiedlungen für Ukraine die das
Leben unter russischer Besatzung nicht
mehr aushalten ist es zunehmend schwer
geworden auf freies ukrainisches
Territorium zu gelangen manche nehmen
sehr lange Wege auf sich quer durch
Kriegsgebiet um zum einzigen
passierbaren Grenzübergang zu kommen den
es aktuell zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine gibt im Nordosten bei krassen
opia von dort berichtet unsere
reporterin Anne Will
es ist eine gefährliche Mission die
Vitali fast täglich unternimmt zum
einzigen offenen Grenzübergang zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine
dann haben wir hier Donna Sana wir
fahren unmittelbar zur Grenzlinie mit
Russland dort gibt es einen
Grenzübergang für Fußgänger die Leute
gehen 1800 Meter der Weg ist schlimm und
es ist sehr
heißer
wird von den Russen ständig beschossen
von hier sind es nur wenige Kilometer
bis zur Grenze mehr dürfen wir nicht
zeigen aus Sicherheitsgründen
[Musik]
plötzlich sind sie da in einem kleinen
Bus schauen wir in lauter erschöpfte
Gesichter alle hier sind aus
ukrainischen Gebieten die von den Russen
besetzt sind wo kommt ihr jetzt her
aus der Region und wie ist die Situation
mental sehr schwer es ist sehr schwer
die Schule ist Russisch wir sind zurück
damit das Kind zur Schule geht
es gibt keine Arbeit
meine Schwester ist dort geblieben wir
warten auf Sie
wer darf gehen wer muss bleiben alles
ist russische Willkür davon erzählt auch
eurer aus
melittopollo man zwingt die Leute dazu
Pässe zu bekommen denn man kann weder in
der Schule lernen noch im Krankenhaus
sich behandeln lassen an der Rezeption
steht geschrieben dass man zur
Sprechstunde nur dann darf wenn man
einen russischen Pass hat
Zwang Unterdrückung Propaganda das sagt
eure sei Alltag in Milito Paulo
sehen will der schaut sie sich an wir
machen das nicht denn da werden
komplette Lügen erzählt denn wir sehen
ja was bei uns in der Stadt vor sich
geht und was berichtet wird alles ist
verdreht
russische Rubel in Fetzen liegen in dem
Raum in dem die Menschen registriert
werden
das ist wie Wut und hasst die sich den
Russen gegenüber angehäuft haben
Vitali und die anderen Freiwilligen
wollen weiter zur Grenze fahren für die
nächste Gruppe ist schon alles
vorbereitet
dass man in Moskau den Befehl gibt
Freiheit und absetzungsbewegungen
niederzuschlagen ist ja kein neues
Phänomen heute vor 55 Jahren wollten die
Panzer in der Tschechoslowakei ein und
beendeten gewaltsam den sogenannten
Prager Frühling das galt damals als die
größte Militäroperation in Europa seit
1945 die Tschechoslowaken wurden
regelrecht überrollt
in der Ukraine sollte es wohl ähnlich
laufen das Putin glaubte er könne das
Nachbarland unterwerfen und dabei
relativ unbehelligt bleiben liegt
vielleicht auch darin begründet dass ihm
in der Vergangenheit kaum Einhalt
geboten wurde etwa in Tschetschenien
oder bei der Annektion der Krim oder in
Syrien Russland das Assad Regime
militärisch unterstützt in einem Krieg
in dem selbst Giftgas eingesetzt wurde
auch da gibt es heute einen bitteren
Jahrestag zehn Jahre ist der Angriff auf
guter Herr andernfalls berichtet
es ist ein Uhr 20 mittwoch der 21 August
2013 es sind zehn wie aus einer
Apokalypse Erinnerungen zehn Jahre
danach
wir warten auf von dem Geschrei Angriff
mit Chemiewaffen Chemiewaffen
Chemiewaffen
guter wird an diesem Morgen zum Ziel
eines der ringasangriffs mit mehr als
1.000 Toten das ist ein Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit zehn Jahre danach ist
sich die Weltgemeinschaft einig das
hinter der Attacke höchstwahrscheinlich
das Regime von Assad steckt für abomalik
ist das Leben seitdem gezeichnet vom
Angriff seine Tochter rital wird wenige
Monate später geboren mit einer
Behinderung eine mögliche Spätfolge die
Familie lebt im Nordwesten Syriens eine
Region die nicht von Assad kontrolliert
wird hier sollten Sie eigentlich von den
Hilfslieferungen der Vereinten Nation
profitieren aber
hier kommt keine Hilfe an hier ist
nichts niemand kümmert sich
und tatsächlich wir finden Hilfe aber
nicht hier im Nordwesten sondern in
Assad Damaskus wir sind unterwegs mit
einer versteckten Kamera diese Bilder
beweisen das was die Vereinten Nation
wohl am meisten fürchten dürften und
fast jeder hier weiß davon nur offen
reden können sie nicht
die Regierung stiehlt die Hilfe
sie verkaufen sie im Einkaufsladen es
gibt aber auch einen ganzen Markt für
Hilfsgüter sie verkaufen dort Reis
Zucker Öl Konserven
auch wir werden fündig weiße Bohnen aus
der USA aus der amerikanischen
Hilfslieferung ja
Sonnenblumenöl vom
Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nationen mit der Inschrift nicht für den
Verkauf bestimmt und dann hunderte
Päckchen Notnahrung für mangelernährte
Kinder das Päckchen im Angebot für
umgerechnet 15 bis 30 Cent Nahrung die
in den Camps im Nordwesten so bittern
nötig wäre seit 41 Tagen kommt nichts
mehr
ich gebe ihnen Tee statt Babynahrung das
ist doch unmenschlich
Blanka das das ausgerechnet der Mann der
Krieg gegen sie führt nun die Kontrolle
habe über ihre Hilfsgüter
und jetzt geht's erstmal bei dir weiter
Heinz mit anderen Nachrichten
kurz bevor die USA und Südkorea ein
gemeinsames Militärmanöver begonnen
haben hat Nordkorea nach eigenen Angaben
strategische Marschflugkörper ins Meer
abgefeuert zur Abschreckung von Feinden
wie es hieß Nordkorea wirft den USA und
Südkorea regelmäßig vor mit ihren
Übungen einen Angriff vorzubereiten
nordkoreanische Staats-
die Menschenrechtsorganisation human
right Swatch wirft saudischen
Grenzwächtern vor hunderte äthiopische
Migranten und Asylsuchende getötet zu
haben die versuchten die jemenitisch
saudische Grenze zu überqueren geschehen
sei das zu der Bericht zwischen März
2022 und Juni dieses Jahres das hätten
Interviews Fotos und Satellitenbilder
ergeben das Auswärtige Amt äußerte sich
besorgt zu den Vorwürfen man verfüge
aber über keine eigenen Erkenntnisse
dazu
in Guatemala hat überraschend der
sozialdemokratische Kandidat arivalo die
Präsidentschaftswahl gewonnen eine Valo
der vor kurzem noch als Außenseite
gegolten hatte erhielt in der Stichwahl
rund 58 Prozent der Stimmen die
unterliegende Kandidatin Torres räumte
allerdings ihre Niederlage zunächst
nicht ein wichtigste Themen im Wahlkampf
waren Kriminalität Korruption Inflation
und Arbeitslosigkeit
die verheerenden Waldbrände auf der
Knarren Insel Teneriffa sind auf
Brandstiftung zurückzuführen da sind
sich die Behörden inzwischen sicher die
Feuerwehrleute kämpfen noch immer gegen
die Flammen noch sei das Feuer nicht
unter Kontrolle das Schlimmste sei aber
vorbei so der Regierungschef der Kanaren
Spaniens Ministerpräsident Sanchez
versprach bei einem Besuch vor Ort
schnelle Hilfe beim Wiederaufbau der
Region
in Griechenland sind zwei weitere große
Waldbrände ausgebrochen einer von ihnen
auf eubör der zweitgrößten Insel des
Landes der andere in der Region bozien
westlich von Athen eine Person kam dabei
ums Leben weiterhin außer Kontrolle ist
zudem ein Brand nahe der Hafenstadt
alexandrupolos den dritten Tag in Folge
kämpfen Einsatzkräfte hier gegen das
Feuer Flugzeuge unterstützen die
Löscharbeiten aus der Luft mehrere
Dörfer mussten evakuiert werden
in den brandgebieten in Kanada soll sich
die Lage jetzt etwas stabilisiert haben
aber es bleibt die schlimmste bekannte
Waldbrand Saison in der Geschichte des
Landes mit schwer fassbaren Dimension 14
Millionen Hektar Wald sollen bereits
verbrannt sein das ist mehr als die
Fläche von ganz Griechenland
es ist ein Flehen um Regen beschablon
den ist eine der Stammes ältesten aus
yellow knife der Hauptstadt der Nordwest
Territorien auf der Flucht haben sie
alle die schon verbrannten Wälder
gesehen die Zerstörung am Wegesrand
Vorboten von noch schlimmeren
das ist unsere Verantwortung uns darum
zu kümmern dass es weitergeht für unsere
Enkel und Urenkel aber das haben wir
nicht getan
von dem kleinen Ort Enterprise haben die
Feier nicht viel übrig gelassen die
Bilder folgen von Hitze Dürre und Winden
die die Flammen einfachen ähneln sich am
Lake shoes Swap tausende Kilometer
entfernt den British Columbia hat ein
Feuer den Ort Scotch Krieg überrollt
insgesamt gibt es in Kanada derzeit rund
1.000 Waldbrände die Hälfte davon außer
Kontrolle am Wochenende traf es die
Vororte von killowna die Hilfskräfte tun
ihr Möglichstes leider oft vergeblich
das hinterlässt Spur
ich will all unseren Feuerwehrleuten
dank normale Menschen sind angetreten um
wie Krieger ihre Dörfer und ihre
Nachbarn zu beschützen sie arbeiten 36
bis 48 Stunden Schichten
in den letzten Tagen fiel ein klein
wenig Regen so dass sie die
Verteidigungslinien halten und neue
ziehen konnten aber jetzt ist es wieder
heiß und trocken mit heftigen Winden die
Menschen die aus yellow knife geflohen
sind haben das Nötigste mitgenommen
wissen dass sie alles andere verlieren
könnten Zuspruch kommt vom
Premierminister
ich habe mich mit einigen geflüchteten
in atmen unterhalten wo sie nach 17 20
25 Stunden fahrt nun in Sicherheit sind
sie waren guten Mutes aber erschüttert
besorgte über das was jetzt geschieht
sie können nur abwarten und wie Becher
Blondinen
um Regen
von den Feuern in Kanada kehren wir
zurückgehen unsere Breitengrade und
gehen an die Ostsee der dabei
Sommerhitze reinspringen wird das Wasser
immer noch als ziemlich frische finden
tatsächlich aber wird die Ostsee immer
wärmer und das ist nicht ihr einziges
Problem berichtet Susanne seid
die Küsten Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns
bekommen regelmäßig Bestnoten für die
Badewasserqualität doch wie es unter der
Wasseroberfläche aussieht ahnen die
wenigsten
den Wissenschaftlern vom
Leibniz-Institut für ostseeforschung
bereitet das Binnenmeer sorgen
die Ostsee ist ganz schön unter Druck
wir haben natürlich zu viel Nährstoffe
immer noch Schadstoffe es wird immer
wärmer altmunition also die Liste wird
nicht kürzer sondern eher länger werden
Probleme mit einer Sonde messen er und
seine Mitarbeiter regelmäßig Temperatur
und Sauerstoff in den küstennahen
Gebieten hier in 15 Metern Tiefe
man sieht dass die Temperatur
hoch ist mit 19 Grad aber besonders auch
in der Tiefe wir noch teils 16 Grad
Celsius haben optimal wären hier 10 bis
12 Grad die Ostsee wird alle zehn Jahre
um 0,6 Grad wärmer das und die vielen
Nährstoffe aus der Landwirtschaft
begünstigen eigenwachstum und damit auch
Sauerstoffmangel in den Küstengebieten
in den flach mehr Gebieten stellen wir
fest das auch immer weniger Sauerstoff
da ist gerade im Spätsommer fehlt da
unten die Luft zum Atmen und von oben
wird zu heiß und das ist gerade für für
den Dorsch aber auch für viele andere
Lebewesen ein ganz fataleszenario im
schlimmsten Fall ersticken die Fische
wie hier 2017 in Eckernförde der
Temperaturanstieg in dem Binnenmeer
bringt zudem den Rhythmus des Herings in
der westlichen Ostsee durcheinander er
zieht gewöhnlich im Februar in den
Greifswalder botten zum Leichen im
thünen Institut für Ostseefischerei
beobachtet Uwe krumme dass es immer
weniger Larven werden
wir stellen fest dass die Heringe
deutlich früher einwandern zwei bis drei
Wochen früher und die Larven die dann
schlüpfen
entwickeln sich dann ein Fenster hinein
in dem noch nicht genug Nahrung da ist
die verhungern viele von denen
verhungern und deswegen haben wir am
Ende des Tages eine deutlich verringerte
nachwuchsproduktion so ist der Bestand
an heringslafen in der Ostsee seit den
90er Jahren auf ein Zehntel
zusammengeschrumpft
Oliver Zielinski sieht trotz allem auch
die Erfolge bei der Rettung des
Binnenmeeres
es ist uns in den letzten Jahren
gelungen die Schadstoffe zu reduzieren
und die Nährstoffe zu reduzieren in die
Ost die in die Ostsee eingeleitet werden
aber durch die Erderwärmung müssen wir
uns im Prinzip doppelt so sehr
anstrengen um einen guten Zustand der
Ostsee wieder zu erreichen
es Bemühen um eine ökologisch
funktionstüchtige Ostsee ein Lebensraum
für Fische und Menschen nicht nur ein
Badeparadies
und dann schauen wir noch mal auf die
deutsche Politik
angesichts der aktuellen selbstzerlegung
der Partei DIE LINKE beginnen Berliner
Beobachter ja schon die Totenglocken zu
Leuten politanalysten sinieren bereits
über mögliche Folgen ihres Untergangs
würde das der SPD zugute kommen oder der
AFD oder könnte es im Gegenteil der AFD
Wähler wegnehmen wenn Sarah Wagenknecht
tatsächlich eine neue Partei gründen
würde noch hat sie das aber nicht getan
und noch kämpft ihre bisherige Partei
ums Überleben Andrea
wohl noch nie war die Linke ihrer
Spaltung so nah wie in diesen Tagen und
auf einmal klingt das was Fraktionschef
Dietmar Bartsch 2021 kurz nach der
desaströsen Bundestagswahl gesagt hat
wie eine düstere Prophezeiung wenn wir
in diesen vier Jahren das nicht
erfolgreich machen dann macht diese
Fraktion des Licht aus seit letztem
Mittwoch ist klar Dietmar Bartsch will
derjenige nicht sein der dieses Licht
ausmachen müsste für den
Fraktionsvorsitz tritt er nicht mehr an
auch seine Co-Vorsitzende Amira Mohammed
Ali will nicht mehr wer dann es gibt
nicht mehr viele politische
Schwergewichte in der Linken die Sinne
Lötsch ist seit 2002 im Bundestag mit
Direktmandat für den
fraktionsvorsitzkandidieren Lötzsch
Hoffnung auf andere eine neue Generation
sowohl Gregor Gysi als auch Dietmar Bart
als auch ich werden ja in jedem Falle
weiterhin aktiv für die Partei auftreten
und an den entsprechenden Stellen auch
mitarbeiten und es ist auch unsere
Aufgabe jüngere zu unterstützen für die
Jüngeren in der Partei steht
Parteichefin Janine Wissler und für
einen Kurs der nicht allen gefällt näher
ran an soziale Bewegungen
klimapolitische radikaler als die Grünen
Wissler könnte für den Fraktionsvorsitz
kandidieren aber auch sie hat viel zu
verlieren es braucht 20 von 39 Stimmen
kriegt sie die nicht wäre sie auch als
Parteichefin angeschlagen sie hält sich
die Kandidatur offen noch
ziehen Sie dann zumindest in Betracht
selbst zu kandidieren
also wir werden die nächsten Tage
Gespräche führen ich möchte da jetzt
nicht spekulieren oder irgendwie vor
Überlegungen
öffentlich an
angehen sondern wir werden das in den
nächsten Tagen miteinander besprechen
Wisla hat Feinde vor allem im
sogenannten Wagenknecht Lager das rund
zehn Abgeordnete zählt Klaus Ernst
bekennt sich inzwischen offen zu einer
neuen Partei
definitiv keine integrative Kraft ja die
Partei gestalten auch mit ihren
Positionen und nachdem die mich dann
auch nicht mehr haben wollen wie ich bin
wenn ich das richtige einschätze werde
ich mir was anderes suchen müssen weiter
politischer Krieg zu bleiben und das
wird dann natürlich die Partei von
Banken nicht sein wenn sie sich denn zu
einer grünen schließen sollte es geht
jetzt auch um die Frage wird die Linke
noch gebraucht und wenn ja welche
während die Linkspartei auf enttäuschte
SPD und Grünen Wähler zielt sehen
Parteienforscher für eine Wagenknecht
Partei eine repräsentationslücke link s
konservativ links autoritär Alternative
auch für AFD Wähler hieße
wenn Sahra Wagen nicht eine komplett
neue Partei gründet dass wir auch sehen
könnten potenziell zum allerersten Mal
eine
Wählermobilisierung weg von der AFD und
das haben wir bislang noch überhaupt
nicht gesehen als erstes braucht die
Linke nun zwei neue Fraktionsvorsitzende
zwei die möglicherweise bald das Licht
in dieser Fraktion ausmachen müssen wenn
aus einer linken zwei Parteien würden
mit Wirtschaft geht es jetzt bei eins
weiter und mit dem Thema Wohnungsbau das
Ifo-Institut berichtet davon einem neuen
Rekord beim Auftragsmangel das haben wir
eine aktuelle Umfrage ergeben sie na
meine was heißt das konkret wie sieht's
aus mit der Bautätigkeit es ist massiv
gesunken und deshalb werden diese
Hilferufe für die lahmende Bauwirtschaft
nun auch immer lauter so debattiert die
Regierung nun über Milliarden
Investitionen und Steuererleichterungen
bis hin zum Start als Bauherren die
Auftragsbücher der Firmen werden Lehrer
durch steigende Zinsen und hohe
Baukosten sind sowohl Investoren als
auch Häuslebauer abgeschreckt laut
Ifo-Institut klagten im Juli 2022
lediglich rund zehn Prozent der
befragten Unternehmen überhaupt
Auftragsmangel in diesem Jahr liegt der
Anteil mit rund 40% deutlich darüber
knapp 19% der Firmen berichteten im Juli
außerdem über abgesagte Projekte
es braut sich ein Sturm zusammen sagt
das Münchner Ifo-Institut und dieser
Mangel an Wohnraum dürfte sich also
tendenziell auch weiter verschärfen zur
Situation am Bau hat sich auch
bauministerin Gallwitz geäußert ist ihre
Einschätzung ja gerade weil der
Baubranche buchstäblich die Energie
ausgeht will bundesbauministerin Klara
geibels nun hier ansetzen sie sagt es
sei im Moment der falsche Zeitpunkt
schärfere Energiestandards für Neubauten
einzufordern bei den jetzigen Baupreisen
und der sinkenden Zahl der Bauanträge
könne man nicht noch strengere Regeln im
Hinblick auf Energieeffizienz fordern
die Boom-Zeiten beim Bau die sind
vorerst Geschichte und nun will Davids
im September ein Hilfspaket für die
angeschlagene Branche vorstellen
vielen Dank
und jetzt zum Sport der frühere
Fußball-Bundesliga Trainer Hannes Wolf
wird neue Direktor für Nachwuchs
Training und Entwicklung beim Deutschen
Fußball-Bund er bleibt zu dem U20
Bundestrainer
bei der Leichtathletik WM in Budapest
hat Gina lückenkämper das Finale über
100 Meter verpasst die Europameisterin
kam als fünfte ihres Halbfinals in 11,18
Sekunden ins Spiel Weltmeisterin ist
Sharky Richardson aus den USA sie
sprintete im Finale in 10,65 Sekunden
bei der Hockey Europameisterschaft in
Mönchengladbach hat das deutsche Team
jetzt beste Chancen auf den Halbfinale
Einzug 3:0 hieß es heute am Ende im
Vorrundenspiel gegen die Niederlande
damit hat die deutsche Mannschaft nun
vier Punkte und steht in ihrer Gruppe an
der Tabellenspitze nächster und letzter
Gegner in der Vorrunde ist am Mittwoch
Frankreich
in Spanien gibt es nach dem Sieg der
Frauen-Nationalmannschaft bei der
Fußball-WM nicht nur Begeisterung
sondern auch einige Irritation mitten im
Jubel über die gewonnene
Weltmeisterschaft Küste der Präsident
des spanischen Fußballverbandes eine
Spielerin erst auf die Wangen und dann
mit Nachdruck auf den Mund über die
Reaktionen darauf und zunächst über die
Freude über den Sieg berichtet Thomas
Walde nach dem Schluss Pfiff war vor dem
Jubel in dieser Halle in Madrid
wir haben in ganz Spanien Geschichte
geschrieben das ist für Frauen super
wichtig das bedeutet sehr viel auf
nationaler Ebene wie auch für die Frauen
sie spielen wunderbar besser als die
Männer Frauen an die Macht
eine Szene überschattete den
jubelverbandchef Luis robiales hier
rechts im Bild küsste die Spielerin
Jennifer er muss so auf den Mund darauf
angesprochen sagte er muss so in
sozialen Medien das habe ihr nicht
gefallen
Spaniens Gleichstellungsministerin
Montero kritisierte den Verbandschef es
ist eine Form der sexuellen Gewalt die
wir Frauen täglich erleiden und die
bisher unsichtbar war und die wir nicht
normalisieren dürfen die Zustimmung
steht im Mittelpunkt nur ein Jahr ist
ein Jahr
Spaniens Zeitungen drückten Freude aus
über den Sieg und Empörung über das
Nachspiel der Kuss hat Jenny nicht
gefallen uns auch nicht am Nachmittag
entschuldigte sich rubiales es war
sicherlich ein Fehler das muss ich
zugeben es war in einem ergreifenden
Moment ohne jegliche böse Absicht es ist
nun mal passiert und es war sehr
spontana so mischt sich in den Jubel das
ein Geständnis dass der Verband Chef dem
Siegtor der Spanierinnen eines
hinzugefügt hat ein Eigentor
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht's mit dem montagskino weiter
oder 00:25 meldet sich dann Sandra Maria
kronewald mit unserem Update morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in Südeuropa und
am Mittelmeer herrscht derzeit eine
ordentliche Hitzewelle mit Temperaturen
von 30 bis 45 Grad und auch bei uns in
Deutschland ist es ja heiß zumindest im
Süden ja und da haben wir es mit 35 Grad
zu tun aber sie sehen hier die Hitze
wird hier eingedellt auf unserer Karte
das bedeutet wir bekommen kühlere
Luftmassen aus dem Nordwesten und dieser
Übergang findet dann mit Pauken und
Trompeten statt also mit Unwettern das
dann zum Freitag wir schauen in die
kommende Nacht und da gibt es etwas
Regen nach Norden sonst ist es
trockenstern klar ganz im Westen bildet
sich sogar Nebel bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 20 Grad im Südwesten
das ist eine tropische Nacht hier 19
Grad Richtung Rhein-Main Gebiete und
deutlich kühler Richtung oder bei 12
Grad
morgen dann im Tagesverlauf viel
Sonnenschein im Westen und im Süden nach
Osten hin gibt es einige Quellwolken und
den östlichen und südlichen
Mittelgebirgen gibt es Schauer und
Gewitter aber dann nur vereinzelt
Temperaturen dazu maximal 35 Grad im
Südwesten Deutschlands die gibt es eine
extreme Wärmebelastung deutlich
angenehmer Richtung Schleswig-Holstein
mit 23 Grad die nächsten Tage gibt's
weitere Schauer und Gewitter meistens
Hitzegewitter bis 35 Grad am Mittwoch
Donnerstag sind die Gewitter schon mal
heftiger und Freitag erwarten wir
Unwetter und damit ein schöner Abend